what's up everybody time once again for
the movie retrospective and we're doing
some more hammer horror yeah matter of
fact i think this is probably like
i don't know i kind of feel like this is
probably like one of the most iconic
hammer horror movies just because it was
kind of the first one to do a lot of the
things that like a lot of the later
hammer movies would do
you know what i mean before boobs became
center stage and hammer horrific now
there were boobs in this let's be fair
i mean it starts dripping with it
eventually
it starts to become you know kind of
like uh kind of like playboy magazine of
the day i mean they don't actually show
any nipple but
they're they were [ __ ]
hammer knew how to get asses into seats
they did indeed they know how to get
young guys to come see these movies and
the the sets
got better as they went but i guess this
is the first one and this is their
introduction to the market well it's not
necessarily the first one because what
ended up happening with this was that
you know hammer studios obviously uh you
know back in the 30s and 40s you had
universal and you had kind of like all
the classic monsters and stuff like that
but then
um the whole gothic thing started kind
of falling by the wayside everybody
started doing more like sci-fi atomic
age kind of stuff
so hammer decides they're gonna put
their hat into the ring we're gonna
revamp all of the old uh you know
universal monsters but we're gonna do it
in glorious full color and we're gonna
put like more blood more smut like what
they could get away with yeah now
actually the first one they did so it
was coming so they were renewing
themselves right right right but they
were just saying we're we're remaking
these dusty old universal monster
classes for a new generation like for
the kids and like i said it's bright
colored blood more sexuality because you
could get away with more yeah you know
in the you know in the late 50s early
60s obviously than you could get away
with in the 1930s and i'm not saying i
really do like the 1930s universal
monster movies too but
they were definitely trying to update it
make it gorier make it sexier you know
and all that kind of car villa was
hammer right
uh that yeah but that was later much
later okay that was late that was
straight up lesbian well that's right
from that's right from the book though
yeah it's from the book but they that
that movie is [ __ ] awesome if you go
if y'all looking for a movie like that
see carmilla
yeah it's good there have been a lot of
adaptations of carmilla because like i
said that's a pretty famous uh it's a
novella actually it's not like a whole
book but yeah so what they did the first
one they did was actually curse of
frankenstein and that was 1957 that also
had christopher lee i think he was the
monster uh and uh peter cushing in it
and because that one was so successful
they're like well [ __ ] we did
frankenstein now we're gonna do
dracula and they said that they really
had no other
actor in mind other than christopher lee
to play dracula and obviously peter
cushing playing van helsing now this
movie
watching it again last night i was
reminded i was like this is 1958.
they got away with a lot of [ __ ] for
1958 i mean it's very tame by today's
standards obviously
but
all of the blood they showed like the
staking and stuff like that they would
not absolutely have not got away with
that good special effects for the day it
did turn into dust at the end uh
and that was actually that scene from
what i heard was like way gorier in the
sense like you could actually like see
him disintegrating and like pulling his
face off and stuff like that
um but some of those i heard that some
of those scenes were actually like lost
over time but i think they found a
japanese print somewhere that still had
some of those so they're trying to like
so i think in 2018 or something they
released like a restored version where
they tried to put a lot of that back in
there
but um yeah but they're they did have a
little bit of problem because like i
said for 1958 uh this was actually
really shocking and you had to think too
that you know horror movies like this
hadn't really been in this like this
technicolor you know what i mean with
all this like bright red blood splashing
everywhere
so you had to think of that as well
so this was a lot of first it was the
first as far as i know first dracula
adaptation in color uh first appearance
of christopher lee is dracula and
obviously he's probably
after bella lugosi and i would even
argue that maybe him and bella lugosi on
equal footing because they kind of came
at the character from a different from
different perspectives but i mean
christopher lee is like the
quintessential
screen dracula i feel like it's like
really really hard to top his
performance but him and bella lugosi
like i said came at it from different
angles
so um this was also the first time that
dracula on screen had fangs
because uh if you didn't know like the
bella lugosi one he didn't have fangs in
that one uh and the first one where they
introduced the red contact lenses
that was the first time that had been
done and also i think it was the first
time that the vampire hunter like van
helsing had like the the box of like
stuff like to fight the vampires like
the stakes and all that kind of stuff so
i think that so this introduced like a
lot of things that became iconic
in vampire movies going forward and it
was kind of like the first time that it
did that so uh now i will say that i
guess because of budgetary constraints
or maybe just because they thought it
would work better as a narrative
this
is not i mean it's sort of faithful to
the original book but not really i mean
they made like a lot of changes they're
not crazy but
they did move some stuff around but like
i said the 1931 version with bella
lugosi that was more based on the stage
play
rather than the novel you've you know
there's not really been a definitive
very very close adaptation i think like
i was watching uh uh the guy like a
cinemassacre he did a really good video
about
all of the different dracula adaptations
and which one was like closest to the
book and i think like the bbc made one
in like 1977 or something like that
which was actually the closest but even
they've changed like a lot of [ __ ]
around now this one what they did
they got rid this i thought this was
kind of interesting and i didn't even
realize this when i was watching it but
they set pretty much the whole thing
in
like
central europe it doesn't have the whole
thing where it's like oh they go to
transylvania and then dracula like comes
to england
they don't have any of that like it's
basically like he's been there forever
yeah it's basically like he's just like
the next country over i think like where
dracula lives at the beginning because i
looked it up i was like where exactly is
this but where dracula lives at the
beginning is in romania somewhere and
then uh but the rest of the action
doesn't actually i don't think it's
supposed to take place in england it was
shot in england obviously but it's
supposed to be in bavaria especially in
germany so it's just kind of like across
the border like the country border so
it's you know there's no ships there's
no they don't do any of that ship
journey or any of that kind of stuff and
so i thought i maybe they just did that
for like i said budgetary reasons and
because they wanted to maybe keep it
shorter because the movie's not very
long it's only like 86 minutes it's my
understanding romania is like the
mississippi of europe isn't it
i have no idea
yeah i heard it's pretty you know i
think it's there but yeah like the
lowest didn't come
yeah yeah like backwoods and kind of
well
yeah it might be but but like i said
that's kind of where they put his thing
so it's not like like i said they didn't
have this whole like ship thing or
anything right and jonathan harker the
character
at the very beginning of the movie you
know because like in the book and in
some of the other adaptations like he's
a real estate agent right and he comes
to sell dracula the property that he's
going to buy back in england
uh in this one he actually goes just you
know in the in the coach uh to because
he's just going like i said across the
border the next country and he just goes
over there like to act as a librarian
uh to kind of catalog all of dracula's
collection of like all his books and
everything so he goes there to do that
but it turns out that he knows that
dracula he already knows that dracula is
a vampire and he's essentially like a
vampire hunter who's working as van
helsing's
protege assistant whatever it is like
they're working as vampire hunters
together so
in a way like i said that's kind of
weird but i can see why they did that
because it kind of gets you to the
action like right away it's like look
everybody knows he's a vampire let's
just kind of like he also knows he's a
vampire so you don't have the whole
thing like he does go to dracula's
castle at first and then there's one of
the vampire brides and all that but he's
not
there there's not like that big long
thing like from the book where he's like
figuring out oh [ __ ] the guy's a vampire
he already knows he's a vampire and he's
gone there under false pretenses to like
destroy him right
so there's that so
uh another thing that they did that was
interesting in this film too was that uh
spoiler alert for a movie from 1958 they
killed jonathan harker off
in the like at the end of the first act
like he comes there to kill dracula
and he gets bit by one of the brides
well actually there's only one bride in
this one
he gets bit by one of the brides
and then he gets turned into a vampire
and then um after like van helsing back
in bavaria or whatever finds out that
jonathan harker like disappeared or
whatever he comes there like figured out
he sees jonathan archer walking around
as a vampire and so he kills him you
know what i mean so jonathan harker dies
and like returns is turned into a
vampire and then dies and then from then
on it kind of goes back to
uh mina and all those people and van
helsing and we're following that so the
thing about it too is that christopher
lee in this
as dracula i think i've seen a couple
things where they talked about him being
in this and they're like he's literally
only in this for nine minutes
which is crazy because it seems like
he's in the whole movie just because his
presence yeah well because his presence
is so
overpowering i think the best thing
about his portrayal in this and he
doesn't talk much in this either um you
know he was in like i think nine movies
where he uh was dracula he wasn't in the
sequel that they made to this which i
think was brides of dracula but that
didn't have christopher lee in it so he
was in the next one which i think was
dracula prince of darkness and i think
in that one he didn't say anything like
he didn't have any lines this one i
think he maybe has a dozen lines maybe
like at the beginning he talks to uh
harker and everything like that but the
rest of it he's just kind of you know
he's just like a monster i i collect too
that because i kind of feel like a lot
of the later vampire movies they tried
to make the vampire more
sympathetic i guess
um i think even bella lugosi's version
kind of did that you know what i say
we're just trying to make him kind of
like elegance and it's always seems like
a nice man you know what i mean this one
they don't make him seem like a nice but
he's a straight-up villain in this one
and i think it was like really well done
because christopher lee is actually
really
um imposing he's actually like really
intimidating he's more he's he's got a
greater physicality than bella yeah i
mean taller and he's just he's a big
[ __ ] i mean well you know we did a
show about christopher lee and uh
yeah and they definitely wanted that to
come across they wanted dracula they
wanted to go back to more like the
dracula from the book where he was more
like a monster
rather than being like a sympathetic
uh kind of thing like in this one he's
very animalistic yeah not to belittle
not to belittle lugosi for lugosi was
[ __ ] master at it he was as well but
like i said they're coming at it from a
different portrayal which is fair
lugosi's vampire was
a smaller more debonair type of guy but
just kind of rat like and sinister
more of a sorcerer kind of a appearance
to him
you know somebody who can mesmerize you
yeah this this you know lee's version is
more kind of like a damn
sid lord
you know he's like a sexual predator
yeah
he's a big dude he looks like he could
beat your ass too yeah he's very very
tall he's very imposing and he was quite
young in this i mean he's still pretty
young like they tried to make him look
uh a little bit older so he would look a
little bit more intimidating but yeah
he's so
large and he just has this like really
imposing presence yeah and he can't tell
his physical condition in terms of he's
in a suit and a cape he's just he looks
massive yeah he's probably thin though i
think i think he was kind of thin but no
he was pretty physical with him doing
mountain climbing and all kinds of stuff
i think christopher lee was pretty
pretty athletic yeah for his time i
think so he wasn't the kind of guy you
wanted to tangle with especially back
then that's what i mean he absolutely
looks like he could beat your ass in
this movie uh just because he's he's
very large he's very
like you said he comes across it's very
very physical very athletic like even
just the way he moved like when they
first introduce him which i love how
they introduce him and this where he
just appears at the top of the stairs
and then like comes down he comes down
even like the walk down the stairs you
can tell that it's like this dude is not
really somebody to be [ __ ] with and he
really kind of really does run around
he's very very like he just moves around
a lot he's very active very lord vader
very dark yeah and i really like that
like i said and they give him like just
such an animalistic kind of thing which
i think worked really well and i think
that was another thing that was sort of
a change up yes the original bella
lugosi version had like kind of a i
don't know like an aristocratic sort of
like romantic type of thing
whereas christopher lee's portrayal is
more like carnal he's like it's very
very it's i always want to say it's
rapey you know what i mean like he he
comes across like i said he's very
animalistic but he's still like really
sexy at the same time
um you know and he's like coming in the
in the bedrooms of like the women and
they're just kind of like oh all right
you know what i mean it's like kind of
that kind of thing which like i said for
1958 was actually like a pretty
controversial thing to be doing he's a
lot more
alpha uh yeah it's like an alpha type
vampire but lugosi's vampire was more
like a sigma
kind of a
type yeah that might be a good way of
putting it you know still slick but not
you know in a different way dude to
snuck in the back door you know that
kind of stuff yeah where yeah lee was a
lot more like intimidating and he was
just like gonna come in and like [ __ ]
grab your ass you know what i mean and
so and that hadn't really been done
before and like i said the fact that
they didn't really make him sympathetic
they made him seem like
they he comes across as like it's
believable that you would be like oh
yeah bite me or whatever but um because
he's like kind of sexy but also that
he's really monstrous and like needs to
be destroyed there's really nothing
sympathetic about him at all and i think
maybe that's not only down to
christopher lee's performance which is
great but i think it's also kind of like
because of how they set the story up
where
at the very beginning like you know like
in the book you almost have a little
thing where harker before he figures out
that dracula is a vampire like they have
some back and forth so it's almost kind
of like you know there's almost like a
relationship or something going on there
whereas in this one harker knows right
away that he's a vampire and i've come
here to destroy him so you you're always
like from the very beginning they've set
it up as like a good versus evil
kind of thing like just right from the
very beginning so you don't really get a
lot of time spent they don't spend a lot
of time establishing
uh you know dracula as a character or
like i said anybody that you should feel
sympathy with um you know they introduce
him and he seems kind of elegant at
first but really only a few minutes in
he starts to like monster out you know
what i mean so he's obviously like a
villain and he's obviously a bad guy and
this is something that has to be fought
again so like i said you kind of then
you kind of like start following van
helsing's character as he's trying to
figure out like how to fight him another
weird thing they did in this too which
i'm always i'm just so fascinated by all
the different
variations of like dracula they just
like why they made particular changes
like i understand why they changed the
whole thing it's like well we need to
take out the whole like transylvania to
england this whole because the book is
very sprawling and takes place on a
couple of like in a couple different
countries it's narrated and it's
narrated
right and it's like yeah and yeah there
there be a way to do that like that it
wouldn't be necessarily boring but i
think that works better in a novel
usually than like in a movie although i
did like coppola's version that kind of
incorporated some of that
but so i understand why they did that
they're like we need to shoot it in bray
studios so we just kind of want it to
look like vaguely germanic or whatever
like central european and we'll just say
well they're just a couple countries
apart so it's not like ships we don't
have to do all that kind of crap but
here's another thing that they did and i
think like a couple of the later films
did this either and i still don't know
why and i wish someone would explain it
to me
they kind of switched
lucy and mina
remember when we talked about the
1979 version with frankly angela they
did it in that one too and i don't
really understand what they did in this
one one oh another thing that i didn't
even notice while i was watching it this
one doesn't have renfield in it either
not at all there's no red field yeah no
which is crazy because i think almost
all the other adaptations had renfield
this one just doesn't even have renfield
um dr seward is in it but he's literally
in one scene and you wouldn't even know
that it was dr seward unless he just
comes in as like he's the family doctor
and they're like yeah i'm gonna get a
second opinion bye it's that kind of
thing so he's not like really a main
character
what they did like i said jonathan
harker gets killed at the end of the
first act like he gets vamped out and
then uh van helsing has to put him down
like put him out of his misery and then
it goes back to bavaria now mina is in
this
but mina is already married and she's
married to arthur holmwood who in the
book arthur holmwood was
lucy's fiance right now you do have lucy
in this but lucy and arthur are brother
and sister
and lucy was engaged to jonathan harker
so harker gets killed and then lucy is
already starting to get sick or what is
already starting to get vampire disease
because the motivation
for dracula as far as i could determine
the motivation for dracula like starting
to pick on lucy and meena and all them
is because he was mad that harker had
killed his vampire bride
his consort and he's like well i'm gonna
take one of your [ __ ] then right it
was basically that kind of like petty
which that's fair enough i mean that's
fine maybe he really liked that one yeah
cause like you know in the book he had
three but like in this movie he just had
one
and here's the thing too i was wondering
about this so
harker gets bit by the vampire bride
like very near the beginning
she at first approaches him and it says
he's holding me here against my will you
have to help me yeah feminine wiles on
him yeah now yeah was she really there
against her will no i maybe she would
maybe she was like at the beginning like
maybe he met her and brought her there
again but yeah she was just tending to
be immortal she was just trying to get
uh
get her close enough that she could like
bite him yeah she was she was trying she
was pretending to be a mortal woman
and the last thing she knew is that she
was being held there as a mortal london
in the grips of a damn vampire so that
was the angle that she used she's like
oh my god playing that role yeah yeah
he's holding me here against my will and
he's like oh yeah she was a vampire yeah
and then she's like yeah sucker yeah
yeah that was that but yeah so um so i
guess like dracula was mad that's a
great lie because the best lie is the
one closest to the truth
he was holding her at first but not
anymore
i guess she knew that he knew that he
was a vampire if not that's a good cover
yeah you know what i mean to just go
with what was you know a lie that is
closest to the truth is the one that
will be believed
so you know
that's what she did yeah i guess so she
just kind of told the truth as it was
back then and that that's passable it
worked kinda
because he knew that
he was that the dude was a vampire yeah
and she didn't tell him that but he he
put two and two together she's like oh
he's gonna turn her into vampire she was
already a vampire yeah yeah little did
he know yeah well that's pretty good
then they started fighting over
yeah because she come because then uh
christopher lee comes in he's like
like all without great iconic yeah like
those red eyes and all this [ __ ]
jimmy's gonna think probably critique
the movie based upon what was included
or excluded from the you know in the
story from the book well i don't know
critique i'm just interested in the
differences i'm i'm gonna critique it on
a lot more basic level
it didn't look good
all right it was too bright
uh the colors weren't that strong the
sets were not very interesting they were
oh i liked the sets i thought they were
boring oh it just didn't have any very
much visual style now it is the 50s
so maybe that
was you know
acceptable then
but they got a lot better looking in the
70s the uh
60s and 70s the way a hammer film looked
the sets looked a lot better so the
costumes
i just thought it
the sets were wrong
it should have looked like a damn
ancient spooky abandoned castle kind of
like you know in the old universal films
but see i think that they i think they
wanted to like get away from that though
because like i said they were trying to
do something like more okay like that
was gothic but for a modern day because
yeah the 30s ones were all like creepy
like cobwebby castles whereas this one
looked like a creepy castle but it was
more like one that looked like they had
a maid yeah you know or okay then if
they're gonna go the way that they went
in this one at least darken it
so you can't see everything so there's
some mystery a little more shadow and
stuff now i have heard it's been a lot
better look the version that we watched
uh was is on hbo max at the moment now
i've heard and i don't know if this is
the version that we saw on there but i
think that the latest blu-ray edition of
it has restored some of the original
color grading and things like that like
that i imagine that the original dp like
intended and i've heard i haven't seen
it but um that is like darker around the
edges and the blacks are deeper like the
shadows are so it is actually like
darker so it probably probably was
insane it will look better maybe because
it looks too much
like a studio set and it looks kind of
televisiony
uh it doesn't look
it needed to be darker
with more vibrant colors
some of the editing
and the camera angles
you wouldn't do that today but i think a
lot a lot of the stuff that they did was
based on the fact that cameras were big
back then and and gamers didn't have
very good tripods and things to set on
back then you couldn't really get a
really intense angle during a fight
scene
uh
blocking the choreography fight
choreography back then wasn't what it
really
would be of course today or even in the
70s the 70s was better
um
so my only problems with it is that it
was not visually impressive
had it been visually impressive i
probably
would have liked a movie better i would
have been more entertained i think
but the acting was good the story was
good it was just kind of visually boring
that was that's my only complaint about
it if you like
if you're big into the british uh
hammer films or if you want to get into
hammer films and uh and christopher lee
as as a dracula this would be probably
where to start this is probably where
you should start because honestly i
think i it's been a while since i've
seen because they made what like seven
eight nine sequels to this now like i
said brides of dracula was the sequel
after this and christopher lee wasn't in
that one but he came back for dracula
prince of darkness and the subsequent
ones but um this is probably the one to
start with because this is the first
time that he played that character and i
think it's like his most
iconic like the later ones are good too
i like those like
great
see i don't know like because it's been
a while since i've seen them like some
of the ones especially some of the ones
that came in like the 70s i felt like
were a little too
dated or a little too like they were
trying too hard to make it groovy
which like dracula 80 1972 yeah which
it's fun but
i don't know i died as a tone right i
couldn't get like down with it whereas
this one seems much more like just a
lean and mean like thriller
without
i mean there is a little bit i think the
only criticism i'd have of it is it i
don't think it needed it had like a
couple scenes of like comic relief quote
unquote like um
i didn't mind the one funny guy like the
one uh he was like a he was the
undertaker right like the undertaker guy
and him making the joke about like
somebody coming to like pay their last
respects and then tripping over a step
and dying and blah blah so that was
funny but i don't think it needed like
they did another scene where
the coach came through and like broke
his gate and then he fixed it all up and
then the coach and then he's like want
you know what i mean so it's like i
don't think it needed that but like i
said this is
hammer they had only done this was only
their second you know gothic horror
thing like i said curse of frankenstein
was the first one that was like a huge
hit this was also a huge hit which is
why they did we see curse of friends
i've seen it but it's been a long time i
don't think i've seen it uh that is also
peter cushing and christopher lee like i
said peter cushing plays dr frankenstein
in that one and uh chris really plays
the monster obviously because like he
said he's why would you put christopher
lee as a damn monster because he's six
foot five yeah i guess is he does he
have you speaking
um i don't think he talks in that damn i
don't think he talks to that okay the um
another thing that was kind of lacking
is that there wasn't a lot of
damn pimped out vampire
special abilities there was some stuff
that
dracula could do as a nosferatu that
wasn't shown here which i think that
they should have shown it
they should have shown him mesmerized
some people [ __ ]
uh i don't remember a single thing where
where he
somebody looked at him and he [ __ ]
froze him with his gaze and you know
what i mean and [ __ ]
did suggestion and like mind control
well dracula could do that kind of right
but the well the thing about it too is
that i mean terence fisher who directed
this and he directed a [ __ ] ton of
hammer movies and jimmy sangster was the
writer on it and one of the things that
they talked about specifically they said
well we kind of felt like the universal
monster movies like the bella lugosi
ones they said those were almost kind of
like a little bit more like fairy tales
and they're like so when we were
updating it for modern we wanted it a
little bit more like obviously it's
supernatural but they wanted it a little
more grounded in reality
so they basically were like there's even
a scene in this where peter cushing like
as van helsing says to i think he says
to arthur holmwood it's like oh you know
it's a myth that vampires can like turn
into bats or whatever the [ __ ] so they
were trying to like ground it more in
reality so yeah he had fangs yeah he
drank blood yeah he lived forever and
yes he was super strong but he didn't
really have any like magical powers and
they did that and they did that on
purpose i'm like [ __ ] on it i'm
gonna say i disagree they shouldn't have
done that
at least if he couldn't turn into some
bats or a wolf or anything like that
you they at least could have explained
it as well they have the power of mental
domination
okay
if you look at them and they make eye
contact with them it's very dangerous
that doesn't cost anything for that
effect the only thing for that effect
would be [ __ ] acting all right and
then you could say they could even make
you think
that they were wolves or disappeared in
a damn cloud of smoke but it's all just
an illusion it's it's suggested into
your mind see that's how you do that you
know what i mean the way that i would
have done it the way they approached
this one and i think that um that peter
cushing even says this at one point in
the movie too was that he compares
vampirism to drug addiction addiction
which is funny because they did that a
lot later like in a lot later movies
this might be the first time that i saw
that comparison made explicit in a movie
so again like kind of ahead of its time
but so yeah he's basically come and
christopher lee even said too that he
was coming at the idea of dracula as
this is a guy who
doesn't necessarily want to keep on
living like this but he doesn't really
have a choice you know what i mean so
he's just like this monstrous kind of
like he just keeps on keeping on and
he's just kind of like sick of the whole
[ __ ] um so yeah but they did explicitly
um compare this to drug addiction and i
will argue too that
while they don't make a like a specific
like mesmerism type of thing
there is a weird kind of and this was
also deliberate because i read an
interview with terence fisher where he
talked about them you know talking about
this
was he's like i want it to be very
overtly sexual that it's like you know
the you know christopher lee comes in
and these ladies you know maybe their
husbands aren't doing it for them
anymore and they're just kind of like
you know dick struck yeah well see
that's the whole vampire
[ __ ] lore yeah mental domination yeah
which they did do and there's a bunch of
just they didn't make it relatively
explain that and show that my high
charisma is mental domination okay
mind control by getting leverage on
people is mental domination some of it
could
be empathetic psychic abilities you know
what i mean or just having a really good
gab [ __ ] sales technique scaring the
[ __ ] out of people is mental domination
so yeah i don't think that's not an
ability you strip from the character of
[ __ ] dracula hell no
but did you see like after he starts
biting the chicks like after he starts
biting lucy like she's you know acting
all like prim and proper and everything
like that but then but then she's like
opening that window going mm-hmm yeah
and then like he bit he bites mina too
yeah and then she's just like
oh yeah you know what i mean it's like
that kind of [ __ ] and they and they did
that very deliberately because they
wanted to make it seem like and like i
said terence fisher even said this he
said i want it particularly when mina
gets bit he's like i wanted to kind of
imply that her husband arthur holmwood
wasn't really like you know satisfying
her right and that she was getting
something from the dracula that she
wasn't getting from like from her
husband yeah and then the whole thing
about a vampire turning into a damn
cloud of mist to escape something i
think that's i i would have i would i
would definitely
let a vampire in my stories do that okay
even if it was just an illusion
you know like like an illusion that was
placed into your head and that's what
you that's how you thought he got out
you know it's like a parlor trick i
would still that's a good ability
and it's
cheap it's cheap to to have an effect
like that with with practical effects
you know smoke machine played in reverse
can do that
or uh fans and [ __ ] you edited it the
right way
and yeah event you know
[ __ ] dracula's there and he falls
into a [ __ ]
cloud of [ __ ] dry ice on the floor
and [ __ ] goes out underneath the damn
door that's a [ __ ] badass shot and
other kind other movies have done it and
i think they should have done it in a
movie like this i don't know though i
kind of you know yeah you could argue
that you like certain things better but
it's just kind of like i i like that
they tried to do something different
and like i said because there had been
so much particularly with the original
universal monster movies they said
because they were more like fairy tales
or because there was more quote-unquote
magic they wanted something that was a
little bit more grounded yeah rather
than
mystical because they thought it would
make it easier to believe like i guess
because they're coming at it from well
we're coming off of
you know particularly in horror and
sci-fi or coming off of like a science
fiction era so they thought that it
would maybe be harder for audiences to
suspend their disbelief right right so i
can see where they were coming from with
that yeah enough special effects and
good enough acting the [ __ ] if they
would have bought it and i'm actually
not sure if they reintroduced some of
the more magical powers in the later
films in the series because i haven't
seen them in a while so i don't remember
look it's very possible that they may
bram strokers dracula came out with uh
you know oh what's his name [ __ ] gary
oldman and that scene where they
cornered the vampire i think it was mean
it was it mina that was uh
that was turning into a vampire yeah and
and he just you see him and he opens up
his cape and he's nothing but just a
mass of [ __ ] rats that hits the
ground and runs away i was impressed man
i was impressed that did look and that
was the 90s and it was a practical
effect
you know yeah it was expensive
but it just yeah that was a very lavish
production whoa
then you have to ask yourself did
dracula really do that or did he just
make you was that his power of
suggestion he made you think he he
exited the room that way and you were so
freaked out you didn't follow him did
you really just walk out the door or
jump out the window or maybe it was yeah
it was like some david david copperfield
[ __ ] he jumped he just jumps out the
window illusion but he gave you a mental
hallucination that he turned into rats
and ran like holy and you're a lot
you're less likely to chase him
[ __ ] i ain't going after that
yeah never mind yeah no i just keep on
keeping on counting yeah okay
i'm not going after a massive damn rat's
like a form up into
so i think that you know because it's
psychological warfare you know so i i i
don't i wouldn't take that from a damn
vampire character just saying you know
yeah and of course mama waldy didn't
really mama waldy could turn into a bat
didn't he turn into a bat or did you
turn it it turned into a bat and flu uh
yeah the effect wasn't that good
yeah but well and maybe that's what they
were afraid of because i mean to be fair
like from the in the 1930s one that
effect wasn't very good either it's like
obviously you could see the string on
the back yeah that kind of stuff so
maybe they just like i said maybe they
thought that was too hokey yeah
particularly for audiences at that time
period who'd already seen the universal
phone he didn't have the experience and
the effects
and how to edit it right and to get it
to get the audience yeah i mean it was
the late 1950s
it was the late 1950s when this came out
and to be honest like for what they were
trying to do and it's not a huge hugely
budgeted i think it cost 81 000 pounds
to make
um so which is nothing
so i mean uh considering that i think
they did a good job and like i said i
you know i know why they made the
choices that they made because i they
thought that this was again like for a
new generation so they wanted to
concentrate more on the physicality of
the drak of dracula they want to
concentrate more on the blood
like more on that kind of stuff than the
more mystical aspects which like i said
you can argue that you like that better
or worse
but that's what they were going for you
know what i'm saying and particularly i
really like my i think my favorite part
of this i really like the parts with uh
with lucy like after she gets vampirized
and turns into
blue for lady they don't actually say
that that's what they called her in the
book but um they didn't uh they didn't
call her that in the movie but yeah
where she's gonna like eat the kid or
whatever so i really like that but i
think my favorite part of this is like
the final fight
between van helsing and uh and dracula
because they're like actual they're
actually fighting you know what i mean
which i thought was kind of cool there's
not this whole you know i'm gonna hold
up but he you know uh
actually like van helsing is actually
really really physical in this too like
he's jumping up on the dining table and
getting the candlesticks and holding the
candle sticks out and then like at the
end he runs down that long table and
jumps up and pulls those [ __ ]
curtains down and then like christopher
lee is like [ __ ] that like he starts
like disintegrating and it's all gross
and [ __ ] skinny guy i mean he probably
weighed 125 pounds
he was [ __ ] running around you
realize that yeah how skinny that dude
is i know yeah and actually well he was
like um it's funny because when they
first asked him to play van helsing uh
he was like that's gonna be he's like
what are you gonna put old man makeup on
because van helsing in the book you know
is an old man yeah uh and he's like
that's really dumb why don't you just
get an old person but they were like no
we want you he's like well then we'll
then i'll just play it as me like i'll
just play it as a younger character
because that would be ridiculous
and i honestly i'm gonna say of all the
dracula movies of all the everything um
i think that i think that he's my
favorite van helsing i mean
he's the most iconic he's probably my
favorite dr frankenstein too gonna be
honest with you i [ __ ] love peter
cushing but um yeah i mean i don't think
there's been a better van helsing i will
say that the strength of this particular
movie is
is van helsing and uh and dracula the
acting's good i mean the two of them are
so [ __ ] great yeah um i'd like to see
the original color uh version of it you
know what i mean with the color
corrections that's what i've heard i've
heard that the original i think it was
2018
if i'm not mistaken maybe one of you
guys knows but not only have they
restored some of the scenes that were
cut out because there were some censored
scenes like with more explicit like
staking scenes i like that which um and
and more shots of uh of dracula
disintegrating yeah at the end because
they did like trim some of that out
because the you know the sensor board
was like
oh no it's 1958. um there wasn't a huge
amount taken out but there were like
little things like that taken out and i
heard that the color grading on it is a
little bit warmer a little bit darker
it's kind of dark around the edges yeah
and the shadows are darker that's what i
heard that's what it needs so like
overall darker probably better someone
it's not just me that noticed it then it
looked washed out and too bright
it wasn't it didn't have a spooky it is
yeah
yeah it is very it is very bright yeah
and yeah maybe there's not like there
maybe there wasn't enough i didn't
really notice because i'm used to like
watching uh hammer films and i'm used to
watching british films from that time
period so they all just kind of look
like that but
yeah i can now that you're talking about
it i can kind of see what you're talking
about where it needed more like contrast
i
needed darker shadows the uh brighter
tone to the colors and and darker you
know what i mean and with in an overall
like a darker filter on it
yeah to make
those interiors seem a little bit more
mysterious and menacing and better
looking to the eye they just look basic
to me yeah you know like something you'd
see made for tv
and it didn't have to be because the
quality of them was pretty good it's
just the way that they were the way they
looked on film the way they were shot
was super basic
just insane i get what you're saying
yeah but yeah i mean honestly yeah if
you're kind of new to hammer films or if
you're new to christopher lee or
anything like that or or peter cushing
for that matter then probably this is
one of the first ones you want to watch
i kind of feel like later the later
hammer flicks look a lot better than
this they were i was expecting one of
the later ones with the color contrast
the darker shadows
and the sets no this was only like their
like i said their second is their second
one it was their first dracula movie so
if you've ever seen the hammer flicks
don't judge hammer flicks based on this
one because they actually get a lot
better looking uh i was expecting one of
the you know with the way expected this
one to be kind of like the way that the
ones i'm used to look which uh which if
it had looked like that i would have
liked it better
although story-wise i think this one
might be a little bit better than even
though like i said it's not all that
like it takes a lot of liberties with
the source material but it's still close
enough to
the story that like you kind of know
what's going on like it has like most of
the stuff that was okay yeah so i
thought and i thought the uh the choices
that they made like to tighten the story
up were actually like good choices i
thought because like i said this is very
short it's only like 86 minutes so they
don't like [ __ ] around you know and uh
as i said i think kind of the best
things about it best things about it
like i said obviously are peter cushing
and christopher lee i mean christopher
lee is so
just everything about his dracula is so
good in this just like if just him
walking across the room
is he just conveys so much like with his
body language i would like some more
dialogue
with him
but like i said i kind of feel like he
wanted to play it more like a monster
more like the original character because
the i mean the
the dracula from the book is not a
romantic
character he's a villain you know i mean
he's
yucky yeah there were some things in
lugosi's version that
that he said that i don't even think
they were from the book
but lugosi lugosi's version said some
cool [ __ ] that really i think conda has
to be said in every vampire like there's
a
part where he's
talking to van helsing and he was saying
that his main strength
is that you do not that you do not
believe
in other words you know
a vampire's his main strength is that
society doesn't believe that he exists
and it just said a lot of
kind of
deep things in a way i mean of course
you know
that's you know
that's kind of a simplistic thing but
just the way he says it it sounds really
important like yeah that's right you can
get a lot of way with a lot of [ __ ]
people don't believe
you know and i don't think cushing said
anything like that there's
no hint of any kind of vampire culture
of how a vampire lives or how vampire
thinks
not really just a monster yeah in this
one he definitely just comes off as like
a a monster like a one and a half and
that he's been around for a long time
and has been preying on the right the
populist for a long time it has to be
kind of taken down you know what i mean
which that's one thing i can kind of
ding it on i think lugosi lugosi loved
that role and he
made sure to put a bunch of stuff in
there and drag you know from dracula's
point of view you know which i think
that's kind of a nice touch
because lugosi loved that role he did a
lot of that role he was doing that role
on stage for long yeah he [ __ ] loved
that that role and i think he partially
i think partially
well no to a large extent
when you think of dracula you're
actually thinking of lugosi's dracula
yeah i mean yeah i mean
he did like introduce i think when you
think of like a modern vampire when you
talk about like modern vampire movies i
think most of that comes from
christopher lee's portrayal but when
you're talking about like the classic
halloween
vampire yeah like the costume and
everything like that that's bella lugosi
yeah i mean that's where all that game
and kind of like a sex symbol type thing
that's the ghosty
uh from the book
that's not really what you're talking
about from what you're from with from
the book
dracula was that he was a nosferatu yeah
he looked like and he had a shrek like a
rat he had a mustache yeah
i was watching like i said i was
watching that cinemassacre thing where
he was talking about he's like you know
the only
uh the only kind of well-known uh
dracula adaptation that actually had
uh dracula have a mustache was jess
franco's version which was also
christopher lee that was not a hammer
movie but that's the only one that he
had a mustache bella had a version where
he played
a vampire but it wasn't dracula because
he didn't have the rights or something
and he was wearing a dab mustache uh
yeah bye to ben yeah he made so many
it was a real bad b movie one but he had
like a little mustache on a little
goatee and i i think pretty sure he was
playing a vampire well now he what did
have a mustache and a goatee in white
zombies maybe
yeah so he wasn't a vampire he was like
a voodoo like a buddhist guy yeah like
of like a guy that did voodoo but he did
i know that he
they tried to make some vampire movies
with lugosi but they couldn't call them
dracula yeah there's like a couple of
those out there
it's just hilarious to me like how many
different they i mean they came up with
this like it's count alucard yeah yeah
count yoga
yeah that was like a 70s one we should
probably do that one i think that one's
i remember being terrible
there was two of them actually there was
one there was a account yoga and then
there was a sequel as well yeah but yeah
we should probably do that as well but
like i said i think christopher lee even
though
he was always trying to get the
character closer to what was in the book
you know to be in it i think he was kind
of disappointed that
hammer kept like going farther and
farther afield but in this one you could
tell that he was trying to go back to
like the og like the the character from
the book where he was much more
like i said much more like animalistic
or imposing he wasn't like romantic
necessarily or sympathetic he wanted him
to just be like this kind of just carnal
monster type of thing and i think he
really succeeded in that yeah you know
although you know they should have had
some transformation scenes or he
he's actually find out maybe when you
look at him he looks like he looked you
know he looks like a man and he plays as
a man but it's all just a uh it's a it's
a trick of the mind he actually looks
like that he actually looks like he
actually looks like a rat nosferatu yeah
and he's casting a glamorous grabbing a
glamour spell
to make me look like hot ass christopher
lee yeah and that's how you see him and
that's how you see him in the film and
that's what you see him when you're
looking at him but it's in your mind
if you go if he goes in front of a
mirror and you look at the mirror you
see what he really looks like
he looks like he looks like nosferatu
that'd be really cool and then when he
gets pissed he can't keep the glamour up
and he turns into you actually see him
i'm gonna be affected or like before
he's gonna attack somebody yeah i don't
i don't know i mean there's been a try
he drops the [ __ ] charade and [ __ ]
you can see where it really looks i mean
there's been a million dracula
adaptations and like offshoots so i
would it wouldn't shock me if somebody
had thought of doing that before but
i've never heard of that being done
but
that actually would be kind of
interesting because why keep up why keep
up the effort if you're going to just
start you know killing somebody anywhere
fighting someone you have time to keep
up the damn look i don't have time to
look good you don't have time to look
good
who fires concentration
just deal with me what i really look
like i look like klaus kanski with a big
old [ __ ] teeth yeah yeah huge ears
teeth and [ __ ] long nose
yeah yeah it'd be kind of harder to like
seduce ladies looking like that though
yeah not impossible but well he could
mesmerize he got mental domination is
scared out of a woman yeah
and it's too late now
that's like the ultimate
beer goggles you wake up next to that in
the morning oh my god what did i do last
night once you turned into a vampire
though
the woman slowly starts to transform her
to look like that too
so it's okay yeah
and she's and she's now like addicted
you know to the damn blood and
everything so it just turns into one of
them that's kind of like uh what that
damn blood vessel movie was remember
with yeah
with the damn what do they call those
things the three yes trigoy
yeah i like this stragoi i didn't hear
and his
his girl was kind of hot it looked like
a hot evil looking rat chick
she was all in on into it and everything
was it was it i have the weirdest boner
right now situation
she just had that rat sexuality
and then they were also sorcerers yeah
they're doing magic yeah they're like
had witchcraft cool yeah that was
actually i really liked that one yeah
and i haven't seen blood vessels yeah
and that was like the original
that's where the stories of vampires
came from
yeah like they're monstrous like that
yeah kind of that's where all this
nosferatu vampire [ __ ] that you
you're hearing from you know bram
stroker he just he just heard stories of
struggle and ripped it off you know it's
stoker right stoker yeah
no you said stroker no i didn't yeah you
did like stroker ace my accent
[Laughter]
bram stroker ace yeah
the match up that we never knew we
needed rams
mouth anyway ram stoker and uh hold to
enunciate i don't know
it's bram stoker and uh and what's his
ass that was in smoky in the bandit yeah
they team up and like yeah driving
around to the [ __ ] train
getting killed it's like i just i'd
invented a whole new i invented a whole
new movie yeah all right so uh is that
are we done talking yeah all right so uh
yeah if you want to see
the first christopher lee dracula movie
it's horror of dracula it's actually
just called dracula in the uk it's just
called horror of dracula in the u.s
because the original dracula from 1931
was apparently still playing in theaters
here uh because it was you know they
re-released it so they didn't want any
confusion so they actually call it
horror of dracula in the united states
it's on hbo max at the moment
and i'm sure you can get it other places
as well but yeah uh check it out or if
you've seen it let us know what you
think about it in the comments and we
will see you again on the next movie
retrospective
bye